رونالدو وميسي في لقاء جديد ربما يكون
الاخير ولكن هذه المره بنكهه عربيه وعلى
ارض الرياض سيكون الموعد المباراه وديه
لكن تابع المنافسه لم يكون غائبا بين
اللاعبي الفريقين لا سيما نجم الكره
العالميه لاخر 20 عاما ميسي ورونالدو
خصوصا انها فرصه ربما تكون اخيره لقاء
حافل بينهما بعد رحيل الدون عن اوروبا صوب
الدوري السعودي ورغم تفوق ميسي بعدد
الكرات الذهبيه التي حققها خلال مسيرته
الا ان الدون خرجوا من اوروبا تركه ورائهم
ميسي في صداره هدافي الدوري الابطال
اللقاء ايضا سيكون فرصه ثانيه لتحسين سجل
الدهون امام ميسي حيث تواجهها قبل ذلك من
ست سنوات
حقق فيها ميسي 16 انتصارا مقابل احد عشر
ليرونالدو و9 تعادلات كذلك كان رونالدو
يسعى في مواجهته الجديده مع ميسي معدلاته
في عدد الاهداف المسجله في المواجهات
بينهما حيث جلال ميسي 22 هدفا مقابل 21
هدف رونالدو